welcome to the show hope everybody had a
good weekend my weekend was notably free
of social media I'll follow up about
that a topic of stunningly high interest
actually when I mentioned it last week
I'll follow up about that later in the
show but let's get right into what's
going on and what happened over the
weekend when we have been having these
conversations about the movement to
impeach Donald Trump we will inevitably
sort of get to a point where someone
will say Republicans aren't going to
participate Republicans won't impeach
Trump no matter what Trump says no
matter what Trump does and that's true I
mean whatever happens Republicans are
going to be an impediment to Donald
Trump's impeachment if it is ever going
to get going and that's not really the
focus of what I want to talk about today
what I want to focus in on is how that
statement can be misunderstood um that
claim Republicans will be an impediment
could easily be misunderstood as what
Nixon did was worse than what Trump did
so the reason that Republicans in 74
were ready to sign on to Richard Nixon's
impeachment which of course was what
precipitated his resignation and
Republicans now are not willing to sign
on to Donald Trump's impeachment the
difference might be misinterpreted as
Trump just hasn't done stuff that's
worthy of impeachment whereas Richard
Nixon did but we've already widely
debunked that notion we actually looked
at the three I guess column
transgressions that were part of the
articles of impeachment against Richard
Nixon and we found that between the
Moller report and all sorts of other
evidence it all points to Donald Trump
having committed all three of the same
transgressions and remember that these
are number one obstruction of the
investigation into a DNC headquarters
being broken into this is Richard
Nixon's articles of impeachment
violating constitutional rights of
citizens and impairing the
administration of justice and failing to
produce papers and things as directed by
duly authorized subpoenas from Congress
without rehashing the entire list item
by item because we did it last week I
don't want to repeat the same story
Trump has done all three of those same
things that were in the articles of
impeachment against Richard Nixon the
difference between Nixon 1974 and Trump
2019 is not the axe it's the Republicans
that are currently in elected office
there's a really good article by Richard
Wolfe and not Wolfe The Economist who
was my professor at UMass when I was an
undergrad Richard Wolfe with an e on the
end the British journalist he has a
great article about this in The Guardian
which were linking to from our YouTube
clip for this story today's Republicans
would not have impeached Richard Nixon
either and that's really what sort of at
the crux of the status quo in which we
find ourselves
if Richard Nixon had today's Republicans
and if he also had Fox News which would
be a pretty big help Nixon would not
have had to resign because Republicans
wouldn't have been about to sign on to
impeachment Nixon also so not only did
Nixon not have today's Republicans not
only did Nixon not have Fox News and the
right wing echo chamber of cable news
and talk radio Nixon also didn't have a
William Barr a professional at covering
up presidential misdeeds and I'll even
go a step further we're on the cusp of
finding out even more transgressions
committed by Donald Trump
remember this stunning moment from the
bar testimony last week where senator
Kamala Harris asked a very simple
question has Trump directed you mr.
Attorney General to investigate specific
people and William Barr was reduced to
sort of a stuttering bubbling buffoon
asking for the question to be repeated
and ultimately saying I just don't know
Thank You mr. chairman attorney general
Barr has the President or anyone at the
White House ever asked or suggested that
you open an investigation of anyone I
wouldn't I wouldn't yes or no question I
will repeat it has the president or
anyone at the White House ever asked or
suggested that you open an investigation
of anyone yes or no please sir the
president or anybody else seems you
would remember something like
and be able to tell us yeah but I'm
trying to grapple with the word suggest
I mean there have been discussions of
matters out there that they have not
asked me to open a investigation but
perhaps they've suggested I don't know I
wouldn't say suggest hinted I don't know
inferred you don't know okay
in the 1970s absolutely disgusting and
brazen abuses of power actually kind of
crossed party lines lawmakers on both
sides said we're Republicans they're
Democrats or we're Democrats and they're
Republicans but abuses of power at this
level cross partisanship it's a red line
of sorts so to speak bad luck for Nixon
but Trump is in a very different
environment and this is actually
something that the people around Trump
have crafted really really well Trump's
propagandists whether it's Stephen ban
and early on Stephen Miller Roger Ailes
when he was around right whoever was
advising Trump about how to deal with
the Moller probe from the beginning they
realized and this is I'm not criticizing
them for this I mean that this is their
team and they ran this really well they
realize that in the 1970s Nixon didn't
have the support of the court of public
opinion and everything came from that
okay so what the people around from
focused on is let's make sure the Fox
News echo chamber is with us let's make
sure we have someone in the Justice
Department who can manage this from a
public relations perspective they
installed William Barr as long as the
court of public opinion supports Trump
which means his base gives enough cover
to Republicans where Republicans don't
have to say damn I I kind of need to
hold the guy accountable or I'm in
jeopardy for my own reelection it gives
Republicans the cover to insist that
this is a witch-hunt that it's
presidential harassment whatever term
you want to apply to it and this is what
you have you can make the case that
Republicans are amoral when it comes to
this and I wouldn't disagree with you
but the most important thing when the
rubber meets the road is that they are a
moral they are amoral in that it's just
a
what can we get away with for our own
personal self-preservation they would
not have impeached Richard Nixon and
that's the real difference not that
Trump and Nixon are so drastically
different in terms of their wrongdoing
in fact there are some really good smart
legal analyses which say there's
political legal analyses which say that
actually there's way more evidence
against Donald Trump and there is than
there was against Richard Nixon for
similar types of misdeeds as I told you
from the three articles of impeachment
against Richard Nixon the difference is
the Republican and a Republican Party
and of course the sort of media
environment surrounding that tell me I'm
wrong I'm ready to have my mind change
would today's Republicans have impeached
Richard Nixon I think the answer is very
clearly no today's program is sponsored
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blinka
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink as comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n